I think that women are getting tricked I
think that's the thing the women are and
I believe that the women who have been
convinced that you know sex is
liberating and all that sex is emotional
and I believe that it is every
relationship affects you deeply in your
inner soul and and people are being lied
to and so I think it's becoming a very
depressed Society although I believe
that men that are listening to this are
the ones that are following in the
player player category are like yeah
that's me I'm getting all the checks and
then the other guys are really sad and
they're getting and so there was a data
that came out from dating apps that
found
it's something like the bell curve for
women is 20 of men they asked women like
rate these men on their attractiveness
and women said basically 80 of men were
below average and only rated the highest
attractive guys as like it's something
like that I forgot the data worked the
the bell curve for men on whether or not
they rated a woman is attractive was a
standard bell curve so it's like these
women are unattractive average is pretty
good and then wow these women are super
attractive women were like all these
guys are ugly except these guys so our
standards are too high they're very high
but women should have high school they
should be yeah but the issue then is you
combine that with modern sexual
Liberation feminism and women are being
told you don't have to be in a
relationship you don't have to expect
anything from the guy and the guys are
like wow it's free I'll take it and so
the top tier guys who are physically fit
attractive and well-off are gonna go on
a date they're gonna hook up with a
woman and then be like we'll do this
again and then he immediately goes in
the app and says next
young men are getting dejected so my
point with all this was they then go to
those young men and say meet your new
girlfriend put your headset on
and this is putting the cow in the VR
headset to make it think it's in a lush
green field there was a there's an app I
think it was replica was that where guys
are dating these AI text Bots because
they're lonely and then the creator of
it took away the dating function because
they were like okay this is getting a
little weird and the users revolted they
were like no my girlfriend's like okay
we're gonna give it back to you but your
grandfather didn't We're not gonna let
anyone else do this because it's getting
weird that's where we're going so it's
like the other options nothing so I'll
have an AI girlfriend and that's only on
your phone like that is the most that is
not immersive that is not an experience
like that's not plugging your head in
and getting you know dopamine and and
the the response uh drugs pumped
directly into your brain this is what
it's getting weird man yeah the version
of what's that movie Lars and the Real
Girl yeah this and like there's I saw
the chat getting all worked up this is
not an endorsement of me saying that
this is something I like I'm saying this
is the reality that we need to prepare
for now because these Technologies are
coming whether we like it or not because
even if the US doesn't know what China's
gonna so they're going to get people to
join the Matrix because you're gonna get
a lot of dejected young men who can't
get relationships and who are lonely
but there's another way they're going to
get people they're going to get people
who have bad breakups and who are
depressed and desperately in love with
the person who left them or
somebody whose loved one dies
well the AIS has like one division you
recreate yep check this out they've
already done this they've taken
someone's Facebook profile everything
they've ever written and turned it into
a chat bot so you can talk to your dead
dad and be like hey Dad remember we did
this yeah it was a great evening on
February 17th I remember that day like
it was yeah you were out they know the
speech patterns and they know all the
memories that's that's weird that's
twisted your your dad dies you turn you
put on the VR and say
user profile John Smith
Chicago you know Chicago Illinois age 73
deceased this date generate and then
boom you're in Chicago hanging out with
your dad and he's like it's good to see
you again and you crying finally get to
talk to your dad again or your mom or
your husband or your wife or your kids
but they're not them no but people are
not need that but people
it people who are grieving and like
they're gonna say plug me in
oh I can see that that could happen but
that's so dangerous what a terrible path
to go down not dangerous for the people
who want to control the systems and and
control what people do it's the perfect
thing for them
but how do you function as a society so
who's making stuff to eat you still have
to have robots
you're gonna have robots do whatever I
mean that is so far off well they're
also telling people to abort their kids
and already a lot of food production is
automated we have big machines doing
most of the work two do you ever you
ever hear the phrase fully automated
luxury communism
that's exactly what people are looking
for so not only is what we're talking
about definitely on the horizon there
are people that are excited for it to
arrive and want to do everything they
can to expedite its arrival fully
automated luxury communism there are
people that don't want to do anything
other than be plugged into the Matrix
and be ha and and be pumped full of the
feel-good drugs because existence itself
leads to suffering so that's because
that's the truth this is where I mean we
talk about having a mental health crisis
in the country or across the globe is
this what happens then the next step is
to make everybody feel better by having
a fake world
well
people are going to choose it
because it feels good
right so are you familiar with fermi's
paradox
this is a it's an idea that represents
if the universe is so big
and life exists why have we not
encountered alien life that's the
question and there's a bunch of
potential Solutions some are that any
sufficiently advanced civilization will
blow itself up like we've developed
nuclear weapons and other crazy things I
happen to think that one of the
strongest contenders as to why we have
not met aliens well for one maybe there
aren't any I don't know but it could be
that
any humans have needs and desires we
need those things to function we have
emotions those things help us survive we
get scared we feel strong connections
and so our
if you do a good thing and accomplish a
goal it feels good that's why video
games are so addictive
I think the thing is
most life if it does exist is going to
chase after whatever it is that gives it
a reward
so what are we going to do we're gonna
make video games we are going to make
video games that give us the reward now
there's drugs you can take that give you
rewards opium right heroin or whatever
opiates they trigger that good euphoric
feeling in your brain and you just
people melt away in it and then die what
we're going to make is
when you get a dopamine hit from
accomplishing something when you feel
strongly connected to a loved one we are
going to simulate that so you feel good
all the time and it is the same thing as
any drug and then instead of traveling
the stars and colonizing new worlds
we're all going to lay down in the Pod
eat the bugs put on the headset and be
happy
now y'all might be saying like that
would make me happy sure but your kids
will
your kids are going to grow up in this
world with this available to them and
you're going to say I don't want my kid
using neural link but then when they're
in school they're gonna be like well how
are they supposed to learn our whole
curriculum is through neuralink you
weirdo homeschoolers and there'll be
holdouts there will be and they'll raise
their kids the right way but how many
conservative parents right now knowing
everything going on are still putting
their kids in public schools saying well
what am I supposed to do I have to work
I can't get my kid out of school yes in
20 years you'll say the exact same thing
what am I supposed to I'm at work you
know I disagree with what they're doing
but my kid uses neural link while your
kid's in the neuraling they're
generating that addiction that
connection and then they're going to be
in their 20s they're going to be like no
time for you Dad plug me in
and they're gonna become the Dragon
Warrior or a carrot or something who
knows I mean it's essentially what we
watch with Avatar
and we'll have worse than that I mean
Avatar at the very least you are still
in the real world you know
well yes to to an extent but I mean
you're still in a body that's not yours
but it's still just your mind in that
world but some of these virtual
universes people might just be a carrot
like the people will identify as crazy
things someone might be like I'm I'm a
rabbit can that there's there's have you
ever heard of uh of other kin
basically trans mythical species so it's
people who think they're trans mythical
species they're a human they're they're
like an elf Mage born in a human body or
they're a dragon born no joke I just
it's like so bizarre so they're gonna be
in the metaverse and they're gonna be
like only in this reality am I my true
self The Dragon King volsenok flying
around the Mystic eight kingdoms
fighting the demons from the nether
realm and and you and you're gonna be
like this is that not real life but
they're they're gonna think to
themselves do I want to work at
McDonald's or be the Dragon Emperor of
the eight Realms Dragon Emperor dude and
they're gonna plug in they're already
doing it people already do this in video
games you know there there are people
who you ask them like what have you done
with your life and they'll say
you know I'm a high I'm a top 10 PVP
World of Warcraft whatever and it's like
that's really great I mean well but if
you're in Esports you might make money
doing that no joke right but some people
dedicate their lives to just being a cog
in the game and not really being the
best person at it and they're not
generating any skill but I mean I'll add
on to that I'll add a layer to that when
we're at the point where our society
says you can be rich and famous for
being good at playing a video game we
are entering the point where we are
eliminating true labor from the
capitalist Market
people are famous now for just posting
pictures of themselves on Instagram
people are making money
by posting pictures on Instagram that
money is then used to travel the world
and do whatever they want
if that's the case
you don't have to do work anymore that's
not work we're calling it work it's
something I mean it's not it's not easy
to make make a living you're still doing
some work but I'm gonna be honest it is
this job that I do here
one million fold easier than tilling a
field and growing crops
that's why I'm here because I don't like
if it was easier to grow crops and work
a farm I'd be doing that but this is
easier so we're really getting to the
point where
sitting around complaining on the
Internet is more lucrative and easier
and we call it work
most of the people posting pictures for
money aren't they doing it as
advertisements
yeah so that's kind of a job
you're you're doing it to get eyeballs
to get to attract influence and then
sell a product of some sort and then
people so so there there's a large
portion of the economy that's turning
into the it's the influencer economy
it's an information economy but that is
also I mean I think that we've seen a
lot of people who have done that and
become
very self-obsessed you know
self-important so then once that starts
to fade when the likes aren't coming
then that is also a depressed Society I
mean it's then they plug themselves into
the neural link and they go back to the
world where everyone loves them or like
if you're not the beautiful influencer
forever like have you lost value gosh
you know I so I come from the the world
of a steel foundry which is a very hard
labor job you know you you are making
product and there's just so much pride
in that you know you make a product it
does things it goes out into the world
it makes it makes trucks move it makes
tractors move it makes people you know
people are able to get products because
of that I mean what how can that go away
people grew up making things that makes
them feel good they were they were
taught they looked up to their parents
they looked up to the prominent members
of their society who were doing these
things and it makes them feel good to
fit in
but now to fit in you got to get
followers on social media so they did
that we talked about this poll where
they asked American Kids what do you
want to be when you grow up and most of
them said like a YouTuber I think was
YouTuber right
Chinese kids were asked they said
astronaut
what is what does being a YouTuber mean
for me it means complaining on the
internet like I really like I think
there's value in it because we're
fighting a culture where we're trying to
keep people focused on the foundations
of this country and what it means to
make a system function
but at the same time I'm like how do I
make more money than a dude who actually
like builds houses
you know that's crazy to me thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time